[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited to start a brief
video series on the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics or
cindy algorithm it's been just about
five years since we first published this
the first cindy paper and so in this
video sequence i'm going to walk you
through
what we've learned since then about how
to compute cindy
to learn models for complex systems and
walk through tons of applications of how
it's been used in the literature
so i'm going to start with a brief
overview cindy is a procedure of taking
time series
data and extracting interpretable
and generalizable dynamical systems
models that describe that data
and i'll talk about what i mean by
interpretable generalizable
later but essentially you can think of
this as a machine learning algorithm
that extracts dynamical systems models
from your time
series data and those dynamical systems
models could take the form of an
ordinary differential equation
x dot equals f of x or a partial
differential
equation partial u of t equals some
nonlinear function
of u in this case x would be
the minimal state needed to describe
your system
and you would be some kind of spatial
temporal field
that's evolving in space and time so to
make this concrete let's say your data
was from this laurent system you know
this chaotic kind of mixing
butterfly attractor all you had was time
series data
of a trajectory or an ensemble of
trajectories moving along
this vector field you would want to
discover a dynamical system of the form
of the actual lorentz equations
so that's what cindy does from time
series data
out of all of the possible models that
could describe it
it comes up with this kind of sparse
minimalistic model
that actually recapitulates the lorentz
model
similarly if i add a movie of flow past
a cylinder of fluid flow
i might want to discover a partial
differential equation like the navy or
stokes equations
that kind of has the minimal key
ingredients needed to describe the
balance
in this case of velocity and vorticity
in this field and
this is kind of generally the philosophy
we're going to take
is that from this data we don't just
want a model
that fits that data there's tons of
machine learning algorithms that will
give
you accurate long-term forecasts of
these dynamical systems
but a lot of those are kind of opaque or
black box models
we really put a premium on getting
equations dynamical systems models that
are sparse
that have as few degrees of freedom
possible that describe
the behavior so that's kind of what
we're looking for here
and this really rests on the idea that
out of all of the possible dynamical
systems that could have described
this lorentz system or this fluid flow
these are actually quite simple the
right hand sides or these differential
equations
only have a very few terms in the
equations the lorentz equations have
seven terms
and likewise the navier-stokes equations
are quite simple out of all the possible
differential equation terms that could
describe them these are both relatively
sparse so that's what we mean by the
sparse identification
of nonlinear dynamics and there's a
third interpretation that we'll talk
about also which is
even if i have a spatial temporal system
a high dimensional system
like this fluid flow i think when i
simulate this i need
approximately a hundred thousand degrees
of freedom in the computer
um you can discover a partial
differential equation
but you might also want to represent
this as a low dimensional combination of
a few
basis modes so oftentimes you can take
these
uh spatial temporal fields like a fluid
flow
and decompose it into a few key
variables in this case this combination
of
three modes with amplitudes x y and z
and you can derive a sparse differential
equation model
in terms of those mode amplitudes and so
this is a classic model from the
literature by barrett noak and
colleagues
that we can discover using the cindy
algorithm purely from measurement data
like this okay that's the mile-high view
of what cindy does
we introduced it in this pnas paper in
2016. so this was work with
josh proctor and nathan kutz my my close
colleagues and collaborators
where we kind of introduced this idea of
trying to learn a dynamical system
with as sparse of a representation as
possible purely from data
and we have kind of this schematic
overview of how the algorithm works i'll
walk you through this in a minute
but the idea is in the last five years
we've learned a ton
about how to compute these cindy models
from data from noisy data
from high dimensional systems stochastic
systems
and you know the capabilities of this
have really dramatically
improved since this first paper so
i thought it would be fun to kind of you
know make a video five years later of
everything we've learned
i get emails all the time of people you
know trying this out on their data
to learn their dynamical systems and so
i want to give you in this series of
videos kind of
insights into where are the pitfalls how
do you actually compute this
and use this as a tool for scientific
discovery
good okay so uh in this kind of
video series what we're going to do is
we're going to walk through the big
picture algorithm
i'm going to tell you kind of all of the
key steps
that are involved in computing these
models from data so that we can get
these interpretable
generalizable models i'm specifically
going to point out
many of the common pitfalls that we run
into or challenges that we face when we
try to learn these models
what kind of data do you need what
coordinate systems are good to measure
in
how do you build the cindy library of
the candidate terms that you're
selecting from
and what optimization algorithms are
most likely to give you kind of
good physical cindy models so this i
think will be multiple
parts of the lecture series i'll have a
whole
a whole video abstract on all of the
cool sparse
non-linear fluids models that we've
developed in my group and with my close
collaborators
over the last five years so this is just
a passion of mine i love
modeling fluid flows and cindy has
turned out to be an
extremely powerful method of getting
kind of low dimensional sparse
interpretable representations of lots of
complex systems from
electro convection to turbulent wakes
fusion reactors and many more so this
will be a whole video i'm really excited
to share with you
we'll talk more broadly about the other
applications of cindy
whether it's for modeling you know
chemical kinetics in the human body
plasma dynamics non-linear optic systems
or
mechanical systems there's tons and tons
of applications
of these sparse nonlinear modeling uh
procedure
and in general i just want us to be
thinking you know there's so many
dynamical systems in the world that
we're interested in
most of the world around us is changing
in time it's constantly changing
some of the systems like this double
pendulum i can write down the laws of
physics you know
from first principles and get a pretty
good model i can use for control but
many other systems like the human brain
or an ecological system a disease
modeling system
we don't have the governing equations
and so these kinds of automated model
discovery techniques
can be really really powerful in those
systems and that's i hope what we do in
the next five years
is really crack some of those big big
scientific discovery problems
okay good so that's what we're going to
do we're going to cover kind of
the overview of the algorithm major
pitfalls
and then get into some key applications
that kind of motivate how and why you
might use this
and also set up some of the problems
that we might want to study in the
future
and i'm going to walk through now an
overview of the cindy method
but i want to motivate why we want
sparsity why do we care
about having minimalistic simplistic
models
and you've heard me say this before i'm
going to say it again
it's very important kind of perspective
in machine learning
is that as we start as we continue to
design
and develop and discover models from
data
that's what machine learning is as we
discover our models from data
of dynamical systems we have to put a
premium on models that are interpretable
and generalizable if we ever want to
have
these models be useful for safety
critical control systems for autopilots
for autonomy for robotic systems
in the loop with humans then we need our
models to be interpretable we need to
understand
what they mean and they need to
generalize outside
of the training data where we train them
instead of defining these two
uh words what i'm going to do is give
you an example
so i think that the ultimate
interpretable and generalizable model
is newton's f equals ma so
it's interpretable in the sense that it
has three terms
f m and a and we can write these down
for a problem of interest we can analyze
explain interpret they have units
and it's generalizable in the sense that
newton can learn
f equals ma from apples falling on earth
that's how the story goes
and this law f equals ma is still valid
when we design
space missions to the moon that's
the ultimate generalizable model so i
guarantee
that you could take movies of apples
falling data from apple's falling and
you could train a deep neural network
to make new movies of apples falling or
to predict the motion of those apples
but that deep neural network is not
going to be useful for space mission
design
unless you take a big step back and
guarantee that you're enforcing
interpretable and generalizable
models so that's what we want we want
models that are more like f equals ma
and less like these big opaque neural
networks
and this is a principle in physical
modeling that's been around for
for thousands of years um from aristotle
until now
that the kind of right physical model is
typically the model that is as simple as
possible
but no simpler and that's a very elegant
statement of this principle of parsimony
that you want the the sparsest the
simplest model possible but no sparser
no simpler
and the way that we enforce this today
with mathematical tools
is by getting models that are low
dimensional that vary
that are described by as few degrees of
freedom as possible
and models that are sparse that have as
few terms in the dynamical system as are
needed to describe
the observed dynamics and that's kind of
the whole philosophy behind this cindy
algorithm is we want
sparse models in terms of a few
variables
now if you fast forward um from newton
until the present computational era
this starts to look a lot like the
lorentz 1963 model
so the lorentz 1963 model is describing
this very very rich
turbulent chaotic convection that you
observe in the atmosphere
and he does it in terms of this very
very simple
three equation model so it's in terms of
a low dimensional state x y and z
which represent the mode amplitudes of
three
important spatial modes and the dynamics
of those three variables
are described in terms of a very simple
ordinary differential equation with
seven
terms most of them linear a few of them
quadratic
so again that's the kind of
interpretable and generalizable model
that we would like
is something like this lorentz model so
that's how i'm going to illustrate the
cindy approach
our sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics algorithm
is on this uh this lorentz system and
again this is joint work with nathan
kutz and josh proctor
we've you know had many many extensions
to this method together in the last five
years
and this is the warm-up problem that we
use to explain
cindy for the first time so we're going
to pretend that we have access
only to data from the laurent system we
know that there are governing equations
but we don't know what they are we just
measure x y and z the state of the
system
in time so every row is a measurement in
time
and we assume that we can compute the
derivatives x dot y dot and z dot
now that's a big assumption and we're
going to relax that assumption in a
minute
but assume you have access to
measurements of the data
in time now the simplest thing that you
could try
would be to model this dynamical system
using a linear model
or a best fit 3x3 a matrix that best
predicts the time derivatives
from the measurement of the state now
and this is what the dynamic mode
decomposition or dmd
would do is essentially it would give
you a best fit three by three model
that would best propagate that system
forward in time
but we know that a three by three linear
model is not going to capture the rich
dynamics of this lorentz system
a simple a matrix has a single fixed
point at the origin
it can't describe the multiple fixed
points of the laurent system the
unstable periodic orbits
or the uh the rich chaotic dynamics that
we observe
so instead what the cindy algorithm does
is it augments the right-hand side of
possible model
terms to include nonlinear terms in
addition to the state itself
so in this case for example in addition
to x y and z
we add terms x squared x y y
squared and all the way up in this case
to fifth order polynomials
so we augment our library to include
more
terms that could be used to describe the
left-hand side the x dot the y-dot and
the z-dot
and notice that all of these uh gray
columns in this theta library
can be computed from the data that i
measured in x y and z
if i have x i can compute x squared if i
have x and y
i can compute x times y and so on so
this is a computable matrix
and now the entire objective of the
cindy algorithm
is to try to find the fewest terms in
this
library of candidate dynamics that
describe the x dot equation
that describe the y dot measurements and
that describe the z dot
measurements okay so for example i'm
trying to find the fewest columns of
theta that add up to equal x dot
that add up to equal y dot and then add
up to equal z dot
now 20 years ago this would have been a
combinatorial brute force search
out of all possible sparse combinations
of columns to find the best fit to x dot
y dot and z dot
now that's a commodity algorithm in
optimization
there are dozens of sparse optimization
algorithms that will give you the
sparsest
subset of theta that adds up to x dot y
dot and z
dot we have our own favorite that i'll
tell you about later but there's lots of
them like the lasso
hard thresholding and so on and so forth
and so when you do this sparse
optimization in this library
you essentially learn the structure of
your dynamical system
and the parameters of what terms are
active
so you learn that the x dot equation is
linear in x and y
which is actually true in the lorentz
equations the y dot equation has a
linear term in
x and y and a nonlinear x z term
and the z dot equations have a z and an
x y
term and in fact that is exactly what
the true lorentz equations are governed
by
and we learn that purely from
measurement data of our system
so this is something that is true in
almost every
system we've looked at where we knew the
answer
is that by imposing this sparsity
condition by trying to find the sparsest
model possible
that that explains the observed data we
tend to discover the actual
true dynamics that generated the data in
the first place
and that's very promising because if we
can rediscover
dynamics that we know using the sparse
algorithm
then hopefully we can discover new
dynamical systems that we don't know
and still have them be interpretable and
generalizable
like these models okay good
now you can do this for ordinary
differential equations like i've shown
you
i'm going to show you all of the
challenges later that you can run into
in did we measure the right variables is
this the right library
what sparse optimization algorithm do i
employ all of those are real challenges
that we'll talk about in
this video series and there's open
source code
uh pi cindy you can download this on
github read about it on joss or on the
archive
and try this out for yourself we want
this to be you know continually getting
better
because of community involvement so so
please try this out
you can also discover partial
differential equations so i alluded to
that in the
intro if i have spatial temporal data
for example this fluid flow past a
cylinder
if i measure the vorticity field omega
and the x and y velocity fields u and v
in space and time i can build a partial
differential
equation model for this so just like in
cindy
we build a regression problem so this is
a generalized linear problem
where we try to represent the time
derivative of some quantity
in this case the time derivative of
vorticity as a sparse combination
of a library of candidate partial
derivatives and nonlinear products of
partial derivatives
so i compute all of these these gray
columns by computing partial derivatives
and
nonlinear cross terms from this data
and i'm trying to find the sparsest
combination of these terms that add up
to equal the time derivative
of omega my vorticity and when we do
this when we apply this sparse
regression
we actually learn purely from data
that the navy or stokes equations are
the dynamics that are most consistent
with the data
and as sparse as possible so this is
fantastic work by sam rudy who is a phd
student working with nathan kutzenme
and he applied this to a ton of other
systems i'll show you in a minute
what's cool is because when you have
this kind of spatial temporal data
there's so much data
you can also massively subsample little
patches of that data in space and time
and even that sub-sampled problem is
still well conditioned enough oftentimes
to learn the true dynamics i'll point
out that there was a parallel paper
by hayden shaffer who also showed very
shortly after
the first cindy paper that you could
extend it to partial differential
equations
so both of these papers kind of extend
cindy to learn
pde systems and since then there have
been tons of cool applications learning
new models that have never been written
down before
for plasma systems and many other
systems
so sam also showed that if you have kind
of an ensemble of random walker data if
you have just like a random walk
and you look at an ensemble of these
kind of uh
these random walk data and you look at
the evolving distribution
of that random walker you can learn
things like
the heat equation which describes kind
of this uh
average motion of this diffusion in time
of these random walkers
which we thought was really cool so you
can apply this either in kind of the
deterministic
or in the ensemble statistical framework
to learn pdes
and he applied it in his first paper to
many many partial differential equations
and again
in every case where we knew the answer
by trying to find the sparsest pde that
described the data
we actually learned the correct dynamics
uh
you know purely from measurement data so
that was kind of
neat okay
so i'm going to kind of wrap up this
video just by pointing out that there
are some
big challenges and that's going to set
up the next
few videos in this sequence so this is
the big picture kind of schematic
overview of cindy
and there are a few key steps you need
to generate some data from a system
you build a library of candidate terms
that could describe
those the dynamics of that data and then
you apply some sparse optimization
to uncover the the sparses combination
are the fewest
dynamics terms needed to describe that
data
and all of those have some real
challenges associated with them
so the first challenge is in the
coordinates how did i know that x y and
z were the right variables to measure
that's not obvious at all if i'm
measuring data from a
from the brain how do i know that what
i'm measuring are the right dynamic
variables
to that admit a sparse dynamical system
so that's a key
first challenge the second challenge is
in the library
even if i measured the right variables
how do i know that my dynamics are
polynomial how do i know that they're
quadratic in cubic
and quartic maybe their signs and
cosines maybe they're bessel's functions
how do i design the library
so that i can get a dynamical system
that's sparse
and accurate the third challenge and
when we
first wrote this paper five years ago we
thought that this was kind of the hard
challenge it turns out this is
maybe the easiest part is the
optimization
what algorithms do i actually use
to get a sparse model once i have the
right coordinates once i have a good
library
how do i actually find the sparsest
combination that give me my dynamical
system
and in this third challenge this is
where a lot of the kind of physics
informed machine learning comes in
if i know partial physics can i in
enforce that in my optimization can i
constrain my optimization to give me
sparse solutions
that are also physical by construction a
lot of interesting questions here as
well
and then there's a zeroth challenge and
we don't always talk about this but this
is super super important
which is the data itself cindy relies on
having
high quality data pretty clean data
uh rapidly sampled in time and enough of
it
that you can kind of disambiguate
different types of dynamical systems and
get the right
model that describes your your system so
there's fundamental questions like how
much data do i need
how fast do i have to sample it what
quality how little noise do i need
and we're going to talk about all of
that in upcoming videos
so if you are interested in learning the
real nuts and bolts of how to do cindy
for model discovery in your system of
interest i'm going to talk about
all of these challenges in the upcoming
videos
and we're also going to talk about key
success stories in fluid dynamics
and in other fields so that you can get
a feeling of how to do this sparse
modeling
in your own problem okay stay tuned
we're going to talk about all of this
coming up soon
thank you
you